okay so we'll be going live in three two
and one
open and welcome
to tonight's planning committee meeting
my name is Peter Richard solver chairing
the meeting this evening some
housekeeping we've made to start with um
first of all uh we're not expecting a
fire alarm if one does go off if you
could kindly follow us to the car park
over the rose we will take your names
off to make sure everyone's safely out
of the building and then send you on
your Merry way
um mobile phones please could you turn
them off or at the very least silent I
know some people will need to use them
so I don't mind that provided it doesn't
disturb the flow of the meeting so as a
minimum please silent but preferably off
and the meeting itself is a meeting in
public is not a public meeting so only
the people that have registered
registered to speak will be permitted to
do so at the appropriate time I'll call
you forward to one of the three seats in
front of us
um and you will be given your allotted
time when you want to start speaking if
you press the button in the middle of
the microphone it will turn red and then
you will be able to speak and you'll be
heard and of course if you could turn it
off when you stop speaking that'd be
great and stay seated again for uh
questions afterwards that would be
terrific
and we are of course being uh live
streamed as we speak and recorded for
later viewing on YouTube should you so
wish to watch this again
uh let me introduce our officers if I
may as well so to my far right we have
Liz jaworska from committee services to
my immediate right we have Sue Mullins
our solicitor and our planners in no
particular order are Alison Willis Tony
Horton and lanika Agnew and my uh
planning manager of the evenings my
immediate left Israel
thank you Mr chairman uh this is just to
confirm that my role is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking thank you thank
you very much let's move into the
meeting agenda proper so first of all
apologies for absence please thank you
chairman we have apologies tonight from
councilor Curtis whom councilor together
is substituting and councilor Crump
thank you very much members do we have
any disclosures of Interest please
Council Mills
thanks Mr chairman
um
item five on the agenda that's the um
uh application two one uh stroke zero
three two nine five uh stroke ful
um
I may say on this particular application
Mr chairman or anything to do with the
gate light I don't know either I've
always objected to again later yeah from
from day one so I feel I'm almost
predetermined on this so I think I
better not um vote on that or sit on the
panel when it's discussed and also item
six on the agenda the Redundant garage
side some Peters Road claims and I am
the ward member and I will be speaking
on that tonight thank you Mr chairman
lovely thank you very much cancer Parry
please
thank you chair
um just to advise apart from the emails
from councilor Rock and councilor
Bromwich I've also received um an email
in connection with the last application
in Kyneton
um I think perhaps from a planning
manager or someone but
okay I'm going to assume that we've all
received that because I was going to
make that declaration as well I can see
everyone nodding I'm going to assume
we're all here with an open mind
once again everyone nodding so we'll
have that blanketed uh Council Rock
please thank you chairman I am the ward
member uh for the application number
four at napping on the hill
um I will be withdrawn from the
committee to speak on that item
um and we'll not be voting upon it
lovely thank you very much anyone else
with any disclosures
note marvelous um everyone happy with
minutes uh I set out counter Mills yes
you've agreed yeah everyone agreed
marvelous I'll sign those later on okay
let's move to our first application then
which is application reference
1803435 out that is former natton bricks
works on napson on the hill opportunity
conversations Alison over to you
thank you Mr chairman
um this Line application development of
up to a hundred dwellings
means of access from the a425 at the
northern boundary of the site and
pedestrian cycle and emergency access
from Brickyard Road at the southern
boundary
all other matters layout scale
appearance and Landscaping are reserved
for subsequent approval
the location is shown by the black dot
the brickworks is located approximately
400 800 meters west of napton on the
hill
so the site comprises of
10.8 hectares of Brownfield land and is
bordered by the A45 to the north
along here
the Oxford canal and Towpath to the West
Brickyard Road to the South
along here
the Quarry closed in the 1970s and the
site has remained unused since then
several industrial units are located to
the west of the site along here
and existing access is located at the
North Boundary where it meets the a425
just at this point
a private Highway spans the length of
the site comprising a single carriageway
track
a secondary access point is located at
this end to the south of the brick to
the South off Brickyard Road
the site is not in the Conservation Area
and the closest
Lister building is napton windmill
there are two rights of way
that lead from the site up towards the
windmill here
the entirety of the site is designated
as a local Wildlife site
the canal itself
along here
is a potential local Wildlife site
napton Hill Quarry triple SI is located
out of the site in this vicinity
and there there are two other local
geological sites within the application
area
so
this is a fairly recent aerial view of
the site
you can see the Corey floor
with a receding marshy area in this area
and the slopes rise steeply up behind
The Terraces up towards the top of the
hill in this direction
up towards the windmill
there are spoil heaps in this area
most of the previously built form was in
this part of the site
but there is made up ground and
contamination all through the this
section
including the northern parcel and a
large Bond along the edge of the canal
there is a private road that runs
through the site from the A45
all of which indicate previously
developed land
so this is an outline application
the only
with this in mind
there are no detailed plans and
elevations this is the parameters plan
that identifies the proposed developable
areas in the orange
so the made neighborhood plan for napton
on the hill is supportive of development
of the site in overall terms
there's a site-specific policy referred
to uh in the revised preferred options
site allocation plan which identifies
napton brickworks is suitable for
housing up to 80 dwellings
and the development is supported by core
strategy policy as11
there's been much developed there's been
much discussion over the numbers up to
100 houses are proposed local residents
and and the sap favor a smaller number
however the application has been
supported by a financial viability
assessment which contains costings for
two scenarios
80 houses and 100 houses
the report has been independently and
rigorously assessed by surveyors
appointed by SDC
the surveyors unambiguous conclusion is
that a hundred unit scheme is necessary
in order to create a viable development
so this slide is the landscape
parameters plan and seeks to demonstrate
that the site can accommodate a range of
dwellings supported by areas of public
open space and ecological areas
this portion of the of the site that
includes the Quarry slopes
and the ecological
ecologically valuable area and the new
Great Crested new ponds will be managed
for nature conservation
the play area
and the other POS around the housing and
along the canal Frontage will be offered
to the parish council or SDC to manage
so one of the challenge challenging
aspects of this site is that it is close
to existing sources of noise from the
industrial these industrial units
which include plant higher haulage power
tools demolition Reclamation and a
vehicle garage with a Rolling Road
the addition of a noise barrier
here
has been modeled which greatly improves
the acoustic environment
it would be located opposite the
industrial units
partially replacing an existing brick
wall on site
which you can see in this Photograph
here
and we'd also have the additional
benefit of helping to screen the view of
the industrial units from within the
site
the fence would be landscaped on both
sides as shown in the section
and this is the view from Brickyard Road
Bridge showing looking across towards
the site with the hill behind and the
acoustic fence in the foreground but set
back to allow some Landscaping
so the next two slides so some views
across the site so these are the spoil
heaps on the Quarry floor
so this is the Quarry Quarry floor
looking up the slope up towards the top
of the windmill
so Quarry floor taken in the opposite
direction looking out towards the canal
so these are the Sandstone Doggers
referred to in the report which are a
local geological site
so this is the view from the Towpath
looking towards the application site
showing the existing brick wall
um which is approximately where the
acoustic barrier would go
so this is a derelict Wharf the edge of
the edge of the site
uh so a view
view into the site looking up towards
the Hill from the canalto path
so
over the last four years since I first
uh this application first landed on my
desk
we've had lengthy detailed discussions
and have explored alternative
developable areas
I'm sure members are aware but the site
has a very long and complex history
where previously consented schemes have
elapsed as they have not been viable
the site is inherently expensive to
develop needing site clearance
stabilization and Remediation
the the challenge with this particular
site has
been to agree a parameters plan that can
deliver the following
it's got to stay away from sources of
noise in the interests of future
residents
in this area
it's got to provide sufficient POS
it's got to stay away from the slope for
landscape biodiversity and geological
reasons
it has to have sufficient surface water
attenuation
adjacent to the canal as the blue areas
it's got to provide Newt and ecological
mitigation areas New Habitat ponds for
the Great Crested newts and a connect a
connecting Corridor between the top and
the bottom of the site
so that's these green dark darker green
areas
it's got to retain the high a highly
sensitive ecological areas which these
red Parts here and here
and it's also got to retain the gap
through the built form
to retain The View up to the windmill
from the canal Towpath
at the same time
the site has got to accommodate up to
100 dwellings in order to be viable
so I believe the current parameters plan
Stripes an appropriate balance
so that that's the end of my
presentation Mr chairman there are a few
updates as per the update sheet
and the the recommendation is that the
application is granted for the reasons
detailed in the report subject to
conditions and notes completion of a
section 106 agreement the wording and
numbering of which is delegated to
officers
okay awesome thank you very much indeed
um let's call our first Speaker of the
evening who is councilor Richard
Woodcock of napton Parish Council
good evening councilor
so once you're settled and comfortable
you'll have three minutes I'll give you
a 30 second warning before your time is
up otherwise if you want to press the
button in the middle the floor is yours
when you're ready
the initial Community consultation for
this application was for a maximum of 80
units site allocation plans 1 2 and 3
all described a maximum of 80 units
most recent liaison with Stratford
District Council planners indicated that
65 units was appropriate for this site
the whole site is a nature reserve and
vital wildlife and ecology requirements
have neither been met nor mitigated
vital environmental considerations from
air quality and noise from existing
nearby industrial units have neither
been met nor mitigated and an Upton Post
Council is wholly unconvinced by the
suggestion of unsightly noise barriers
triple glazing house orientation and
bizarrely the requirement for residents
to keep their Windows shut
approximately 35 of the 100 units
proposed would need to be built on land
in the open Countryside rather than on
the footprint of the original Brownfield
site contributing various core strategy
and neighborhood development plan
policies and principles
this entire remote site outside the
village of Neptune fails the
sustainability test and in particular
there are no specific improvements
proposed for either the main a425
Gumtree Road or Brickyard Road at the
rear of the site which enable the safe
passage of pedestrians and cyclists to
and from the village
the main entrance and the only vehicular
access to the site is from the busy a425
which is situated immediately adjacent
to the humpback Canal Bridge it's a
really strict Envision for those
Vehicles entering or leaving the complex
The increased number of vehicle
movements to and from the village and
the site caused by an increase in
numbers from 65 units to 100 units would
place an intolerable burden on the
village roads and infrastructure
particularly around the safety safe
route to school policies and a
neighborhood development plan
finally napton is quoted as having the
worst sewage disposal situation in
England and there are severe doubts from
notable experts but problems relating to
this site can be overcome without
compromising the adjacent canal and
ecosystem
then Upton Parish Council have been an
extensive liaison with Stratford
District Council planning department for
almost five years concerning the
potential development of this Brownfield
site and we feel very let down by the
recommendation to Grant the application
for 100 houses despite previous
expectation to limit numbers to no more
than 80 units 30 seconds despite the
reality that no further progress has
been made to mitigate the Syria short
Force described
please can the planning committee be in
no doubt that despite the Neptune Parish
Council and the local communities
initial interest in developing this site
for housing the current application is
not supported and is in fact objected to
in the strongest possible terms we ask
that you refuse it tonight and send it
back to the drawing board thank you
Council work out well within your time
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions Council Parry please
um I just wonder whether you can advise
when you when the parish last conducted
a housing needs survey and if the parish
has a need for affordable housing
all right the parish council lasted its
housing needs survey in the process of
doing its made and neighborhood
development plan which
I was a member of that committee and I
think that would be probably four years
ago now
um there was a need in there for small
housing and affordable housing in the
village
and um
we are actually advised though that any
any numbers that come from this
particular site will not be counted in
our housing allocation because it's
outside the Bilter barrier boundary
and it's a bit of a concern to us to be
frank that if there is affordable
housing on the site then people may not
have pedestrian access to the Village or
cycle access
the councilman I see a signal cancer
melt yes thank you good evening
um I know we've got some bus stops uh
I'm going to be excited how far are we
are you from this or how far is this
development from the school
to calculate broad I would estimate
probably
three quarters or maybe even a mile
okay any other questions members
cancer
so you mentioned that some of the
development in the plants will be built
on not on the Brownfield area but on the
Green Fields could you tell me a little
bit more about that
yes if we refer back to the site plan
presented by Alison Withers um there's
the initial
um footprint from the Brownfield side
which is the sort of circular bits that
you can see in the center but there's
also some housing proposed down by the
main a425 road by the entrance that has
always been Open Meadow it's never been
industrial sites and so about it
probably probably about a third of the
site that's proposed to be built on will
not in fact be Brownfield site and we
were initially advised that that
wouldn't be allowed
do you have a second one please thank
you
um you mentioned this outside the built
up area boundaries so this is against
your NDP is it
I'm not sure it's certainly outside the
built a period boundary and however as a
Brownfield site I think it's got a
special uh designation under the core
strategy okay
okay we might have to follow that up
with the clarification from officers
later on Council Mills unless anyone
else has got any questions we will say
thank you very much to council Wilcox
for your time and contribution this
evening thank you thank you for
listening thank you foreign
next speaker on this item who is Mr
miles wild Smith
on behalf of our applicant
so Mr Alan Smith as you've probably
determined you'll have three minutes
I'll give you 30 second warning whenever
you're ready if you press the button in
the middle of the floor will be yours
well firstly thank you very much for
this opportunity to address the planning
committee this evening on behalf of my
clients and Phillips I'd firstly like to
thank the officer Alison for her
preparation of a thorough and
professional report into this planning
application an earlier presentation to
committee and on that basis I'll try not
to avoid repeating anything that Alison
has already gone over uh already so the
key issue before this planning committee
this evening is whether the planning
application before you complies with the
policies within the adopted development
plan importantly the napton on the hill
neighbor plan and both adopted an
emerging planning policy support
residential development in this location
and on this site in portney is one of
the few Brownfield sites in the district
and of this scale that can make a
tangible contribution towards avoiding
development on the green belt and on
other Greenfield sites
the applicant submit in an indicative
layout which demonstrates how the
applicant is sought to bring forward and
utilize the site in the most efficient
manner focusing development on
previously developed land whilst
delivering sustainable
substantial public open space well in
excess of planning policy requirements
throughout the site the delivery of new
housing and open space on the site will
deliver environmental improvements
through biodiversity net gain and
ecological areas and result in the
removal of anti-social behaviors that
have been taking place over a number of
years although an outline application as
the officer has highlighted the
applicant has worked proactively and
extensively with both the council and
statutory consulties to resolve any
technical concerns that have been raised
throughout the application and to
demonstrate also that the development
could deliver a sustainable development
which would mitigate any of its impacts
to this end the applicant has worked the
council's environmental health officer
to agree that a landscaped acoustic
barrier along the canal could be
implemented which would provide a
sustainable acoustic mitigation strategy
to enable acceptable noise levels to be
met on the site and this will of course
be dealt with through the reserve
matters at the due course in terms of
the proposed site access Arrangements
highways offices are satisfied that
subjects planning conditions permission
should be grown wanted to enable the
development to proceed and the internal
Highway layout would form part of any
reserve matters application and details
will be submitted accordingly to
maximize any footpath and cycle
connections and ensure adequate parking
provision as set out in the committee
report a financial viability assessment
has been submitted and scrutinized
heavily by the council's independently
appointed advisor
as the officer again has highlighted
owing to the constraints of the site it
has been suitably and adequately
demonstrated that a hundred unit scheme
is necessary on the site 30 seconds and
as confirmed in the report the
development would also make significant
contributions to affordable housing
highways and public transport
Improvement public rights away and the
canal Towpath amongst other things as
well as biodiversity netk
ah chair the applicants believe the
scheme fully complies with the policy
requirements of the adopted development
plan and indeed the emerging site
allocations plan and would respectfully
request that the application is approved
per the recommendations of the officer's
report thank you very much
spot someone designed thank you very
much indeed members do we have any
questions for our applicant's agent
no
Council post together
so
um am I right to understand that the 100
units
um they're valuable but the viability is
still only up to 23 affordable houses
rather than the 35 percent that it's
within our policy that is correct yes
but there to achieve that we've we've
delivered a more balanced housing mix to
ensure that more smaller units will be
delivered for for younger and family
targeted housing so yes that's correct
it is lower but there is um it is sort
of balancing acts in essence to deliver
a wide range of housing alongside other
contributions towards education
Healthcare
Etc as well as deliver improvements to
the canal tow path
okay do we have any other questions
no Mr marsmith thank you very much for
your time contribution this evening
so our last week on this item is Council
Nigel Rock Council Rock come on down
and so you probably know you'll have
five minutes I'll give you 30 second
warning and again whenever you're sat
comfortable and ready to go press the
button in the middle and the floor is
yours
thank you chairman can I ask the officer
if any of the pictures I have provided
are permissible to look at
there's a picture and a plan with some
bubbles on it
so if I could have the picture first
that would be helpful
at what point do you want your plan with
the bubbles on and we'll get that ready
to go well we'll have the picture first
but I can start talking chairman if that
uh what I don't want to do is have a
break halfway through your five minutes
and then while we find another picture
so we'll get them both ready yeah that's
quite at the right time there's only two
so uh
oh fine and the next one's got the
bubbles on it so
right okay well over to you right thank
you very much chairman um
firstly what is the drive to Grant this
application and I think it's worth
saying that not in the report is that
there is an extent permission for
commercial development on this side it's
not latched well our policies start from
the general assumptions it's better to
have development on previously built
upon land rather than Green Fields but
both are subject to clear considerations
of ecological balance
the report sets out the criteria for
Brownfield starts from our policy as11
and overwhelmingly these criteria are
not met by the scheme and I refer to
page 12 12 of the report where these are
listed
in paragraph a the delivery of local
targets cannot be met with our required
affordable homes figure of 35 being
reduced to 23 percent
then in paragraph B the former scale
requirements are not met because the
proposals brawls beyond the previously
built upon land into what I think and
the parish council thinks are on
Disturbed Meadows and fails the test set
out in the napton naval development plan
for environmental factors in clause 9.22
and I can read this out if you like on
page 13 in paragraph C would the
proposal be beneficial to Nature the
statement in the officer's report
reaches a different conclusion to that
of the county ecologists and I'm going
to quote for his objection
WCC continues to recommend refusal of
this application WCC ecology cannot find
justification where a high impact
habitat cannot be avoided WCC ecology
cannot be confident that appropriate
consideration has been given as to how
functionality of the important habitats
features and species will be maintained
during and after the development to
maintain May retain the site's County
value
also on page 13 in paragraph D the
highway measures require additional
Street lighting and thus light pollution
apart from any Street lighting within
the proposed development or other design
factors which is currently a dark area
finally for paragraph F the site is
remote from local local services and
only can be practically accessed by
private car for normal household
purposes thus I'll conclude the proposal
fails most of the tests for compliance
with as11 going to have that Matlab
please
Allison
I'm not being am I being paused
I'll be nice and I have if you want to
carry on talking while I listen to us
yeah
the environmental health officer has
raised nose concerns that beset the
Southwest part of the side due to the
proximity of the industrial activities
and the potential noise nuisance to
house occupiers
but in the absence of a detailed scheme
to invest to assess and avoid this harm
is obliged to stop short of an objection
it is summer hope that a future
non-intrusive design involving tall
noise barriers will work but this at the
moment cannot be demonstrated and we
appear to be storing up problems for the
future
the other assumed driver for approval
has existed for some years
is a given an absolute need to provide
housing in the village
this may have been the case in the past
when we had different sustainability
criteria did not have other pressures on
the infrastructure in the southern area
and didn't have a fardier housing Supply
we now have a housing supply of 10.06
years pressure on schools doctors
surgeries and sewage issues
finally we have the draft site
allocation plan with a specific
allocation rural one referred to in the
report
this allocation was specifically and
actively removed by The Examiner from
napton's neighborhood development plan
so as a driver for development it can be
attributed little weight
however if we do assume it's validity
and applicability it sets out 19 bullet
points as requirements 18 are mandated
and one optional
six of these requirements are not met
the committee has to balance if this is
a public ice or as it is now alleged if
there is an overwhelming need for
housing on this scale in this location
versus the proposal's failure to meet
the affordable home requirements it's
damage to biodiversity and habitat
protection it's failure to meet the
criteria in the site allocation plan and
the pressure on the sewage
infrastructure which has the worst
record in the country
this game is therefore in contravention
of policies for Brownfield a certain
biodiversity CS2 water CS4 environment
CS6 affordable housing cs18 napton labor
development clause 9.22 and six
requirements of the sap rural one I
believe it should be refused
Brock thank you you've excellent you had
plenty left
um numbers do we have any questions for
our war member please
no okay Council Rock thank you very much
for your time contribution this evening
so members we have finished our speakers
we will move two points of clarification
for our officers I'm assuming we've got
a few councilor Jennings will kick us
off
thank you chairman just wanted
clarification on Brownfield
um is that within the whole site is that
all classified as Brownfield or just
certain segments of it
we're just getting the slides sorted out
at the moment
let's play with this
so
uh so
so your question was about which which
areas of brownfields type it's the whole
site classified as brown belt because
it's all previously developed land in my
opinion
um when I look through the environmental
Port report that was submitted with the
planning application it and I it not
only does it identify
this area but it also includes this area
as being
a fund along the canal Towpath and a
road that goes through it all of which
are development and also this area and
various other parts along here there's
evidence of contamination as well which
indicates some sort of previous use
so I don't think I would describe it as
a Greenfield site
okay any other points to be clarified
no I had a list of wrote down from
everyone else
um okay so first of all um Allison I
think there was some talk about access
to the Village
um uh being made I think the Parish
Council made this point
I see that we've got a cycleway and
pedestrian way
um could you indicate on the map where
that is um and whether indeed it
connects to the Village or how people
are going to get to the Village from the
site
so I've got a shown a plan
uh so obviously the application site is
in red
um
if you can just see my cursor
um so there are two rights of way that
connect the application site to the
Village that's this one
and this one
the section 106 requests include money
to uh to upgrade and maintain the public
rights of way
um the the vehicular access to the site
will be through the existing access onto
the a425
um if I can refer you to the report the
report identifies a whole range of uh
highways improvements and improvements
to footways and lighting and bus stops
and crossings that are being
funded to improve the linkages into the
Village
um the the access at this end at the
south side of the site is purely for
uh emergency vehicles and pedestrians
and
uh cyclists Brickyard Road itself is
very narrow and quite Steep and it's not
suitable we did explore it at the very
outset but it's just not suitable to be
widened and it's not suitable to put
either a cycleway or a footpath in there
because it's it it's narrow with
hedgerows on both sides
okay so in essence there's access
through the rights of way that are being
improved at the courtesy of the funding
that's been provided through the 106 and
there's improvements to the highway as
well and access from that for both
pedestrians including pedestrians
because the footway is going to leave
from the site to join up to the existing
uh for footpath uh including lighting as
well okay lovely um uh we talked about
some I think Council might have asked
the question about the sap and the NDP
was this part of the NDP
um I know it's in the snap condition
Enlighten us about the relationship with
the NDP as well please so the made
neighborhood plans for napton on the
hill is supportive of the development on
the site in overall terms objective
eight of the NDP is quote to support
appropriate development on Brownfield
land specifically rating relating to the
site of napton brickworks in addition
Community aspiration 3 which is
specifically about the former napton
brickworks states that
the parish council welcome discussions
and involvement in the future
uh in the future of the former napton
brickwork site and paragraph 9.22 of the
NDP
states that the parish council supports
the general principle of residential
development on the site of the former
napton brickworks subject to
environmental and social factors being
satisfactory met
so there's not a specific policy in the
made NDP it was removed by the develop
by the inspector okay so it's an
in-principal support
um subject to detail in essence it
sounds it sounds to me like that okay
um uh Council Rock referred to an extent
development for commercial along on the
sites yeah um I don't necessarily see
that within the um summary of summary
history
um I can only assume it means I was
referring to the 2008 outline proposal
there was
um
there was a consent in 1995 for business
for business park
and in
2008 uh there was an application
submitted which was subsequently
approved in 2015 for mixed-use
development like live work units and
some B1 offices and I think uh
10 houses and some holiday lets but it
didn't include any affordable housing
and it had an off-site contribution for
affordable housing but it was never
subject to the financial viability
assessment and neither sites have ever
come forward to be developed and I can
only conclude that they weren't viable
okay had it been made extent if indeed
it is presumably presumably it covers
the whole site that in itself uh makes
this proves to develop land does it not
and therefore Brownfield is that is that
a fair assessment or am I blanketing it
too much I think it has lapsed though
okay
implemented it would still be previously
development land
that's what I was looking for thank you
um and I think this is the last one
sorry guys and this is a long exhaustive
list
um the county ecology team we've heard
it's got an objection I can see that on
page 10.
um they also whilst they object they
also have a series it seems of um of
conditions am I right in thinking that
uh your assessment has been those
conditions get put in place
um and the benefit of The Wider benefits
of the application outweighs the
objection that has been put forward is
that a fair assessment uh yes it's a
balancing exercise as a
um whilst the majority of the site
um that the site is valuable for across
the site because it provides a whole
range of habitats
um there's only actually about 20 22 of
the most important habitats that are
being lost
uh they will be mitigated uh and they're
going to be you know they're going to be
created Elsewhere on the site
um
but
but always in the back of my mind I'm
conscious that
if you looked at the ecological survey
that was done in 2005 and looked at the
ecological survey that was done now it's
very evident and the county ecologists
have recognized this that the site
itself is gradually reducing in
biodiversity uh its biodiversity
intrinsic biodiversity value because of
natural secession so the open habitats
are becoming
closed and invaded by larger vegetation
which is is changing the character of it
in 2005 there was a very large marshy
area which is then subsequently being
drained so it's lost that aspect of its
ecological value and the longer time
goes on
the invertebrates who are
who are on the site will be less able to
thrive there
that's lovely that covers my list
Council Jennings
just for clarification then with our
requirement for 35 affordable homes
um is that fixed in stone or is that
preferable or is there flexibility due
to circumstances I think the wording of
the course recipology is preferable I
mean essentially what we did
um when we initially
the the initial Financial viability
assessment had
um
35
technically 35 housing on it but it was
provided in a less than
desirable mix so we've used the same
amount of money I've been discussed it
with a housing policy team and we
provide suggested and work with the
developers and uh
housing policy to provide for the same
uh overall figure I suppose a more
locally appropriate mix
so the intention was to provide more
family houses rather than more smaller
units for example
Council Parry
thank you chair obviously this is an
outline application but I'm just
obviously
um it's been highlighted by both the
parish council and the ward member about
their concerns regarding the sewage
system
um and obviously there's no objection
from Seven Trent which is a consultee if
committee was minded to Grant would
would would the be possibility of some
form of condition that ensured that a
very comprehensive
sewage survey analysis would need to be
done before the reserve matters
application came forward
um yes we've already drafted conditions
and we have conditions recommended by
the llfa and I have actually gone
further than that and asked for the the
information is submitted priority or
with the reserve matters application so
it the if say that the application came
back to committee members would be able
to scrutinize it
Council postcard
sorry
um going back to
um connectivity and active travel it's
not just the state of the food path is
actually the distance because I think we
have a policy for our distant
um the settlement should be to working
distance of a school for example and we
heard that mainly you know the housing
mix is for to attract young families so
do we know how distant is the the
footpath the right way to the to the
closest Primary School please
um
um I it's approximately uh from the
North or the south of the of the site
it's approximately a mile to drive to
the primary school
um it's obviously shorter to go to use
either of the rights of way but
obviously it is over a hill
so
so is so yeah but because we have like
their Healthy Communities policy so it's
we don't know the distance from this
proposed new settlement to the primary
school by foot yes it's about a mile one
mile yes
okay and that could be a bit more it is
that a bit higher than I think it's 1.2
this is 1.2 kilometers that you have to
have the maximum distance of primary
school I don't know but there is there
is a um
I think it's fair to say Obviously
that's a mile walking
um or driving on the roads which which
go around the hill if you go straight
across the head it's less than a mile
because it's more more of a straight
line but we don't have an exact figure
of that because it's obviously a cookie
line it's hard to measure but it would
be less than a mile straight across
foreign
ification
before we move into debates no let's
kick off the debate who would like to
start us off in debates councilor Mills
thanks for Jim actually probably Council
Perry still and I found a little bit on
the uh on the club occasion on this
sewage problem Mr chairman we're told
that this is um napped on the hill has a
worse sewage problem in England
um I'm just a little bit concerned how
this is going to improve it uh sewage
problem so that is my concern at the
moment Mr chairman thank you
Council Mills anyone else who's coming
in next cancer Parry please
thank you chair obviously
um I've I've taken a lot of trouble to
look at look at the report and listen to
the parish council and the award member
um but what we have in front of us is an
outline application
um the outline application the the site
is already identified in the napton
neighborhood development plan as
potential for residential development
appreciate it was for 80 houses not 100
but we have a viability
um
Financial assessment that has been
carried out
um we have confirmation from the parish
council that there is a need for
affordable housing in the parish
um we are talking about a Brownfield
site in its totality according to the
planning officer I appreciate there are
many concerns but it's on the basis of
what we have in front of us because it's
an outline plan we're not able to see
the design and the development or get
further information on how that site
would Connect into the sewage system I
see no material planning reason that I
can find to refuse this application and
therefore put a proposal to
branch thank you very much Council Parry
Council Jennings please
councilor Paris said a lot of what I was
going to say
um I'm happy to go straight in there and
second the motion
marvelous thank you very much anyone
else want to speak
cancer
um
eldo is an outline application
one of that is that we are quite low
lower to the policy cs18 which is 35
percent and I'm I'm kind of struggling
because the you know they're putting up
the number of houses to 100 from 80
which is what um you know it's at the
moment in the emerging South africation
plan
but then again you don't get the benefit
of the 35 percent of affordable housing
and I know I mean it's liability is just
that it's really it's quite a lower to
35 and I go obviously a concern about
that
um and the other bit is the
um you know how the settlement
um links to the services because
obviously they have to go up the hill
and you know they and you know they yet
also go into their car drive around to
the services I mean that's you know that
that's against again our policy of
wealthy um communities
um and and active travel and I'm afraid
also our Net Zero um carbon targets uh
to reduce car travel
so
you know that they are my concerns
thank you very much anyone else wish to
make any contributions before we move to
a vote
now we have approached to Grant him when
lying with those recommendation
I'm going to end up throwing one of
these microphones away soon enough
um sorry about that we do occasionally
have Gremlins in our systems so the
proposal is to Grant um I wonder which
way cancer Dixon's going um could I have
a show of hands for those in favor of
granting please
seven and those against
three any abstentions no uh committee
therefore resolves to Grant application
eighteen zero three four three five out
let's form an apps and brickworks and
that's on the hill
let's move to our next item which is
application reference 21 zero three two
nine five fuel that is land at Kingston
Field farm in lighthorn Heath our
presenting officer is Tony Horton uh
Tony you said something good to go
no problem
so I representative is Tony Horton Tony
over to you thank you chair
so this application is for a detailed
planning application for 35 dwellings
at a site known as Kingston Farm
Kingston Fields Farm Bungalow and the
slide in front of you is actually taken
from the core strategy
plan for the this Show's an allocation
of land for the new settlement that gave
the light on Heath which we are now
referring to as upper light on but some
of the slides may have glh on it for for
that purpose so the application site is
indicated by the the red circle there so
you can see it's within the allocated
land which is made up of both
residential
so a thousand dwellings in the homes
England area here two thousand houses in
the CG land here a new Village Center
denoted by the black triangle further
south there's 100 hectares of land for
Jaguar Land Rover four and a half
hectares of land for Aston Martin
Lagonda here this is the site of an old
white lives Quarry
um part of that's for residential phase
one and the rest of it is will become a
managed Ecological Reserve and then
sports facilities and sports Pavilion in
this area here so that is an overview of
the new settlement and as you can see
the application site Falls squarely
within that
just take you to the next slide
so the application sites in edged in red
there so on the sides at the moment
there's an existing Bungalow Kingston
Fields Farm Bungalow and there are a
number of outbuildings here all of which
will be demolished
um
the residential cartilage area is this
Square here and then the rest of the
site is effectively agricultural field
to the side of the side here you've got
Kingston Fields Farmhouse and then the
associated Farm Complex there
and then over the road the b400 Banbury
Road you've got the the Beltway phase
one site which is uh nearly been
completed with the the build out there
and then obviously the surrounding land
is the allocated land uh the homes
England residential Consortium
and then the land for the Village Center
I should also say there are a number of
TPO trees in the vicinity there's a
large group area here outside the sides
and there are a number of individual TPO
trees along the the site Frontage
so this is a an aerial shot
so very roughly the side-edged red is
indicated there so it gives you an
overview of how the side fits in with
the bellway side phase one the homes
England Landing the front we've got the
B4 100 Banbury Road uh bisecting the
photo there Village Center land you've
got this area of TPO trees
and then you've got housing Consortium
land and in the background there you've
got the Consortium phase 2A development
which has been built out by a Consortium
of house builders currently
lights on Heath Village and then these
large building series The jlr and AML
another aerial view looking towards the
north this time
we've got the b4100 Chesterton Woods in
the background the M40 Motorway homes
England land the application sites
those darker green strips you can see
are the remnants of archaeological field
evaluation trenches that were dug I
didn't find any fines of any
significance
that is the I'll just say that the
aerial view does force shorten the the
size of the site which is uh one hectare
and then photograph from the front uh
looking from the the Bell wave phase one
Development Across to the side so it's
behind the the trees uh there it runs
roughly from
about there and then this comes to about
halfway down the sides if I show you the
next slide
that shows looking from the north
southwards towards light on Heath
Village
so you see a new Footwear cycleway is
going on on the the bellway phase one
site three meters wide that links to an
informal crossing that's gone in you can
see there's new road markings and new 30
mile an hour uh speed limits being put
down this um this stretch of the road
and the application site layout so
the access is directly off the B for 100
so if you remember the informal Crossing
on the photograph so it's south of that
before you get to the um the bellway
phase one the uh access development
further to the South so it's a mix of 35
detached semi-detached terraced units
there are provisos for footway cycleway
links to the neighboring land
uh the main adoptable Highway shown in
the dark gray and then coming off there
are secondary routes and then leading on
to private drives
uh you can also see the garden areas
there all the gardens are above the
guideline standards as set in the
council's SPD on the matter
and just looking back from the access
point so these are the visibility
suppliers from the access where it will
go into the site so this is looking to
the south towards
towards light on Heath and the Beltway
phase one site so the bellway access
point is down there so you can see
there's no conflict with the the
positioning of the access with the
bellway configuration and then looking
to the north
so you can see the informal Crossing
points but the the access to the site
will be well before that
um
and visibility displays are good
and then
show you the house types
these are um
a range of the the front elevations of
the house types that we have on the site
you can see there's a element of brick
and tile and some of the key plots on
the site will be picked out in a
reconstituted stone that's the
um
match what's taken place on the key
plots on the Beltway side opposite and
it was also a reference back to the fact
that locally white lice Stone was
quarried
and this is akin to to that in character
and appearance
I think chairman that's uh that's all I
need to present at this stage
um other than to say the recommendation
is to Grant permissions subject to the
completion of a legal agreement and
conditions as laid in out in the report
thank you sir Tony thank you very much
indeed um our first Speaker registered
on this item isn't councilor Jackie
Harris on behalf of upper light horn
Parish Council
you are registered for two slots
tonight's your lucky thing so uh you
presumably have something from the
parish council for us
no problem at all obviously we've
resolved it with committee Services
yourself for me to speak I hope they
won't need the full full time no problem
so so you'll have three minutes and I'll
give you 30 second warning um whenever
you're ready to start on behalf of the
pressure Council the floor is yours oh
thank you
um firstly I've been involved in the the
glh as tone is referred to since about
2015
as councilor Mills said we've all
objected to that initial Grant obviously
it went through it's gone through and I
think it's been positively received by
the local Parish Council which was like
horn Heath has now changed to a polite
horn that said a lot of work was done
around the road infrastructure and the
main topics of community cohesion what
we wanted to do was integrate light horn
Heath with the new build and not leave
it as a carbuncle on the side we still
have many outstanding issues over health
and secondary education provision that
have not been resolved and I just wanted
to give that update to committee members
who were involved or haven't been
involved where we are so remember
Community cohesion and the roads we had
many multi-agency meetings with them
County and it was quite um an
interesting time well I would say and
think Tony would agree but hours of work
was put into that so
what we're objecting to is transport and
Access housing and density
we feel the application has come too
early and it's not demonstrating the
integration that we wanted to see with
upper like horned settlement it doesn't
seem to pay any regard to the overall
settlement and development particularly
as we funded for two years a community
occasion officer so we didn't have the
problems that may unveil and other areas
that have had
so transport and access transport access
to 3 000 homes glh depends entirely on
the success of the new spine road which
is to run parallel with the b4100 with
no more than three roundabout controlled
access points one of which is shared
with AML traffic the root of that spine
road is clearly defined in the phase two
master plan and access from AML
roundabout including a phase three route
out of the Village Center to serve a
future development phase what is missing
here is the phase one master plan for
the Village Center which is the Kingpin
and Fulcrum of the entire glh
development and the cohesion of how it's
all going to integrate together was
around that
they feel it's not acceptable that it's
the site has separate access from B4 100
so close to the engineered belway's home
right turn lane where Vision displays
and safe egress cannot be maintained it
is clear from the SPD that all internal
Housing Development on the glh site
shall be served by an independent spine
Road and the Kingston Fields Farm site
albeit a late addition to the
development should not be the exception
to that constraint 30 seconds the
I will say then the rest of the document
is already on the system and the other
issue was housing and density in
conclusion they feel it's too early for
the overall development and cohesionable
polite horn to let this go ahead at this
time and I'm asking that the conditions
could be is going to go ahead and be
granted that the cohesion and the road
infrastructure is looked at and we'll
put some conditions around that
perfect timing thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for our counselor on behalf of the
parish council Parry please
good evening councilman Harris lovely to
see you thank you
um I just wonder whether you could just
pinpoint the material planning reason
that you are objecting to this
application because you talk about
cohesion but I just would just like to
hone in on there a little bit
um
well the main thing for me I haven't got
it was never a material thing and that's
I think why it went forward in the
original planning but we've both spent
so many hours of of trying to build
[Music]
a community as a whole because what we
were feeling was that like horn Heath
would be left as the carbuncle on the
side and what we've tried to draw in was
the road infrastructure was the
connectivity between both areas
um I up the Topham head at the moment
haven't got
one boy to be together sorry a bit
nervous cancer Dixon please
thank you chairman
uh looking at that plan I'm assuming the
spine Road does not go through that site
and therefore would I be right in
thinking that the parish council's
opinion is that that site should not be
developed before the Village Center yeah
thank you
I don't think there's an overall
objection per se I think that of what
they're saying and how we feel and I
like Council Mill support them is that
it's not the right time at the moment
Castle Rock
thank you chairman I think you've given
us a bit more insight to what it is the
summary on here
um you'll recognize that we take our
Gardens from the County Council
regarding Road layouts
and a presumably with this Junction is
just out off this picture but I think
you've said something slightly more
detailed on here about the turn right
lane into the the the Beltway side
um I mean you know to be honest we're a
bit stuck here at the County Council
said it's all right we're a bit stuck
but the problem you're expressing is not
as much a proximity to the junction but
there's a turn right lane which is is
going to overlap that or it's too close
to it is that what what you're saying
and I just wonder if we could when we
get to officers questions I think we
need to perhaps understand that a bit
more is that
that is correct and no disrespect to the
County Council but they have had things
wrong recently and even laying the
recent Road they got it all wrong we had
to go back and change it and it was
causing difficulties so I would rather
trust what Tony Horton says in the
County Council
anyone else
no in that case Council Harris thanks
very much you are of course registered
as woman Ward member so you'll have
another go in a second you lucky thing
okay we will call on next speaker now
forgive me if I get the pronunciation of
your surname wrong but I believe it's
Miss Katie Christo
phew
come on down
so miss Christie you'll have three
minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning whenever you're ready
comfortable and set to go if you press
the button in the middle of the floor is
for you
good evening
colors the planning application before
you represents a sustainable development
of 35 new homes within an area allocated
for a new settlement at Gaiden liked on
Heath the principle of delivering Homes
at the site is therefore already
established the proposal provides for a
mix of house sizes including smaller
homes in response to local needs this
will contribute towards creating a broad
housing offer as part of the wider new
settlement
the development will provide a total of
12 affordable homes comprising of 75
social rented and 25 shared ownership
homes
and this is accepted by the council as
providing a policy compliant market and
affordable housing mix
the detailed layout responds to the
features of the site and the local
context and this includes compliance
with the council's cada and light one
Heath supplementary planning document to
ensure the development successfully
integrates with the wider settlement
new footpath and cycle links will be
secured by condition to connect the
development with the neighboring areas
including the new Village Center
the design of the development responds
to the principles established by the
supplementary planning document an
average density of 35 dwellings to the
hectare is achieved through a mix of
house types in disperse with areas of
high quality Landscaping
all homes are two stories in height with
the exception of a limited number of Two
and a Half story homes to terminate the
Key Vista within the site and to
contribute towards local distinctiveness
all homes comply with the nationally
described space standards homes are
environmentally sustainable with essos
heat pumps water boats and electric
vehicle charging points provided to all
homes bespoke features such as chimneys
and dummy Windows contribute to high
quality design of the development
engagement with the parish council and
local residents as part of a public
exhibition we have worked positively
with officers over a 12-month period
since the application was submitted and
to reach a recommendation for approval
30 seconds the development constitutes a
high quality and sustainable scheme and
would respectfully request counselors to
support the planning officers
recommendation and to Grant approval for
this application
I didn't need to give you that warning
did I thank you very much indeed members
do we have any questions for our
applicant's agent please
no
counseling seraphin
hello did you mention ground Source heat
pumps in these houses
am I correct
um so we're proposing air source heat
pumps um to all homes okay thank you
anyone else
no Miss Christie's thank you very much
for your time contribution this evening
our last week when this item is once
again Council Jackie Harris
so this time you've got five minutes
with a 30 second warning feel free to
use as much or as little as you like
over to you
thank you might not be as nervous now
um
historically we've worked on this as a
council since about 2015 and probably Mr
Horton a lot longer than that and
certainly um other councilors
seem to recollect and maybe somebody can
ask or Mr Horton might be able to remind
me there were some issues around the
height of the dwellings and the line
with Chesterton windmill an agreement
with developers and conversations around
planning of The Limited um to heightened
The View across the landscape
that said um housing numbers and density
recognizing that this site has always
been included in the wider development
of upper light on the issue here is one
of density the application appears to be
favoring maximizing the land available
and provides little or no public open
space no clear opportunity for
integrating with proposed adjoining
Village Center
in addition it's inappropriate to
include a 2.5 story dwelling on the site
on such a high Contour the 2.5 story
apartments on the bellway site are
situated down the Hillside and do not
include on the landscape or detract from
the overall Concept in the SPD of
housing along the b4100
the 35dph should be seen as a suggestion
for the park Edge site and not a Target
density again and we feel that this
application is too early for the overall
development and cohesion of upper light
on thank you chair
thanks Harris thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for
Council Harris as War member Council
Rock
um
I didn't know whether to ask you or or
when you were pretending to be the
parish council but the business about
the two and a half story dwellings on
the high contour and I see that's been
raised by both Parish councils so we
can't actually see this on the plan but
I take it where these are is the highest
part of the site
so your concern appears not to be
the concept of the site but the detail
of some of the design
and the second point you've raised is
about the public open space now there's
another development to the side of this
which is supposed to link with but
there's public open space in there is
there not so collectively we've got
public open space throughout so these
are two design issues which is which is
your problem rather than a strategic one
have I summarized that correctly yeah I
would say so that's why we haven't got
any grounds as councilor Parry raised it
is a concern I think there's been a
positive view from local residents and
the local Parish councils not only the
main one is or polite on but just to
turn and light on and I think Mr Horton
will agree I think there's been great
partnership working on this and I don't
feel there's a an absolute no to the
objection it's got to be done right we
as a council and the parish councils and
our planning especially Mr Horton have
spent a long time trying to get this
light it's a big development and it
should be right and we just think it's
premature maybe some more time needs and
consideration around the roads the Open
Spaces and certainly the height of the
building specifically we spent a lot of
time in the past on these issues to get
it right then just to ride rough shot
over them
and then go ahead with this then why are
we doing all that work before and said
no we've kept it with the minimization
across the area and the less intrusive
damage onto chest it's in Windmill and
historical sites I think Mr Horton might
be able to give more details on that but
I certainly know that we've spent a lot
of time and we just need to get it right
particularly the community cohesion to
blend it all together
thank you councilor Harris members do we
have any other questions for Council
Harris please
no thank you very much for your time
contribution
okay so points of clarification to our
officers would anyone like to ask any
questions councilor Jennings was first
difference in height between the two and
a two and a half Story House Crews
okay so the two and a half story uh
units there's two of them they're a pair
of semi-detached they are 10.4 meters
high to the ridge
uh the other houses showing on these
slides this one's 9.5
9.3 and 8.4 is the lowest
um there is a good design reason for the
pair of firm of Two and a Half story
which I can elaborate on if you wish
yes please
Okay so
if you look at the layout the two and a
half
story
units are here
and they form the terminal view so when
you come into the site and turn left
into this part of the site your view
down here will be of these two units and
they will frame that terminal view as
you would refer to it as a design
feature
um I'd also say that the glh SPD which
covers the whole of the site does allow
for two and a half story units within
this area and I can show a character
area plan which which has got that on if
you wish
I don't think you need to go that far
thank you
yeah do you have any more cancer
Jennings or are you is that you done
Council pair together next please
thank you so the lack of public open
space because I I would expect with such
um you know large development to have at
least
um some some type of open space and as
well because my understanding is that
the Village Center and the Open Spaces
linked to The Wider development they are
quite you know um they're not going to
be available soon so
I don't know okay can you tell us a
little bit because obviously we got
policy for public open spaces in you
know such development
yep certainly so this plan here shows um
the kind of The Wider parameters of the
CG land so that area in pink is the
Village Center where the school walk
going and the school playing fields and
uh
around there you've got a series of
interconnecting green corridors which
between them have a number of play areas
so there will be a community garden in
this area here there's a
leap here
a a large play area here and here and
then another one here and so this is on
the CG land over the roads you've got
the managed Ecological Reserve which
will grant public access to it
and then Downing lights on Heath Village
there's a playing field and play
equipment down here so
because it's only 35 dwellings
the amount of public open space that you
can generate from that and put it on the
side makes very relatively small parcels
and not particularly usable and and
appropriate so instead of placing it on
site because there are all these other
elements of public open space that are
going to be delivered around it
what the suggestion is to take money for
off-site upgrade of the um the
facilities in the local Village
it could be in light all Heath or
possibly the in this area here there's
tennis courts and
and Cricket facility and allotments so
monies could go to those existing
facilities off-site but still be within
the bounds of walking and cycling from
the application sites
um does that help yeah so can there be
conditioned then if if
um you know okay can you condition the
money to go to
um the local facilities
it would be an obligation in the section
106 agreement if recommendation is to
grant that would be drawn up and then
the the elements of what the money can
be used for and where it can be used
will be clarified at that stage with the
the council solicitors
councilor Perry please thank you chair
um councilor Harris made some reference
to the Chesterton windmill
um but would I be right in thinking
that's probably one to two miles away
from this particular site
approximately it is whilst the reviews
to it because it's up high it is some
considerable distance
it is I don't need it exactly but I I
believe it's sort of one to two miles
something like that it would be
um
in in the region of that yes
um councilor Harris is quite right that
we have taken particular
um concerns about the views from the
windmill and that was a large part of
the outline
um application stage
this particular site in itself is quite
contained though because it's got some a
series of hedgerows and trees around it
and uh the reports the landscape report
related to this is it's a very inward
looking site that's not particularly
visible from the extremities and the
other point
um which also councilor Harris was
stressing was the importance of
community cohesion is there any
um sort of indication of time scale for
the development of the adjacent land
that would
give obviously this development Greater
Community cohesion because of the
facilities that have been built out in
the new Village
yes the as you can see the the black
triangle next to the sides here is is
what will be the Village Center so the
existing Primary School from light on
Heath is being relocated over to their
um the time frame for that is to be set
by the County Council as the educational
Authority but somewhere in the region of
450 occupations on the main side they
start getting the land delivered to them
and it can start thinking about getting
their application in for the new school
the rest of the Village Center
um roughly about a thousand occupations
of the three of the three thousand
um
of the 2000 sorry that that starts to
come forward
um by CG and they've got a group called
The Hinton group working with them and
they're just on the cusp of going out to
the public for a Village Center design
Breeze brief exercise where people will
see which bits of the village are going
where and can have their say and and
comments on that as stakeholders
so delivery is still somewhere for some
elements of it but other elements will
come forward sooner so for example
there's there's hope to get a
supermarket on the site by 500
occupations
at the moment we're about 250
occupations
so I would estimate that this
application site once it's gone through
the process of the legal agreement
gone out to house builders and then
they've discharged the various
conditions we're likely to be in the
region of 18 months to two years away
from developments
Castle Rock
uh character Jennings and councilor
Parry I've asked 90 of the question that
I was about to ask which is which is
back to the two and a half story houses
um and on the view of the windmill so
that there wasn't anything in any master
plan documents or any guidance documents
about the view of the windmill and and
also it's been pointed out although uh
and thank you for the answer about the
ridge Heights but it's been pointed out
they're on a higher uh elevation at
ground level already so there's there's
really nothing in policy that would
restrict that view I mean we haven't got
protected view or anything or any master
plan document or anything like that
there's there's really no basis for us
um having any comment on that
I think the the most sensitive part of
the the
entire allocation is the homes England
land because that has got more open
views towards the windmill and there's a
particular design aspect of that which
has got a windmill view which keeps an
open not undeveloped view through to the
windmill
um but just on this particular site as I
say
um it's quite contained due to the the
um the the elements of the the
surrounding Landscaping
um and just to clarify about the the
heights the land
um this is the topographical survey so
where the two and a half story dwellings
are going which is about this location
here uh we're at about 122 meters above
sea level but in fact I it's quite
deceptive on site you wouldn't think
that there was this changing levels but
the site actually gets higher the
further you go into this corner and this
corner so where the boundary of the
domestic Garden is you go to 123
Midfield 124 and you're three meters
higher than
um in these corners from the point where
the two and a half stories are going so
although this is higher land than some
of the other land around it this
particular site this is actually lower
part of the site where the two and a
half story units would go
okay any other points clarification
before we move into debates
let's move into debates councilor
Jennings please
I understand the thoughts of the the
parish reward members and their
objections
um however there'll be plenty of
community space coming down the line
plus the contributions to the existing
facilities which will benefit people
sooner rather than later
the access is excessive is acceptable to
highways and they're the experts we have
to go on with what they say so again
happy there I don't have a problem with
the two and a half story houses after
looking at the the land because the land
on the south is a meter higher so
therefore that
the discrepancy there is it's actually
going to be lower by 0.2 still from the
top to the bottom
um 12 affordable houses it's compliant
and they'll be delivered sooner rather
than later
um
I can see no material planning reasons
to go against the officer's
recommendations I'm happy to propose
that we Grant this application thank you
very much councilor Kendall please thank
you Council Jennings said a lot of what
I would say so I'll just save time in
just a second The Proposal if that's
okay lovely stuff thanks very much
anyone else want to say anything in
debate
note we have proposal to Grant in line
with officer recommendation subject to
completion of the s106 could have a
shelf hands for those in favor please
that is unanimous so committee therefore
results to Grant application 2103 295
ful which is land at Kingston Field farm
in light horn Heath fabulous let's move
to our last item of the evening
which is application reference
2200720 ful there's a redundant garage
site in Kyneton and our presenting
officer will be lanika Agnew Atlantic as
soon as you're set comfortable and ready
to go the floor is yours
foreign okay lanika I think is all set
up and ready to go so lanika over to you
thank you very much chairman
so the application site is located in
the village of Kyneton and is marked
here by a black circle on the map
this slide shows the application site
outlined in red the site comprises of a
parcel of land of 0.165 hectares and
Falls within the build-up area boundary
for the main Rural Center of Kyneton at
present the site currently accommodates
44 single-story garages in three rows
the site is located along Saint Peter's
Road and is accessed from the southern
road to the northwest
the following slides show the context of
the existing site
current use of the site is for
residential garages as seen on screen
these are brick construction with mono
pitch roofs covered with corrugated
asbestos
the buildings are considered to be too
narrow for modern day vehicles and this
is noted the eight of the 44 garages are
currently used for storage purposes
there is a pedestrian footpath which
runs along the western boundary of the
application site and provides access to
the recreational playing fields to the
north
the application seeks planning
permission for the demolition of the
garages and the erection of five
dwelling houses and Associated
development including a detached garage
to surfplot one
the application proposes to construct
one detached four-bedroom dwelling as
seen on plot one
two three-bedroom semi-detached
dwellings plot two and three and two two
bedroom semi-detached dwellings plot
four and five
the development is to become a private
road and the dwellings would utilize the
remodels but existing vehicle access
point from Saint Peters Road and 13
parking spaces are proposed to serve
this new residential development
the following plan illustrates the
proposed Street Scene facing to the
South the materials used include red
brick and cream render reflective of the
locality
the development scheme also proposes
indicative hard and soft Landscaping
including a 1.8 meter high concrete post
and close boarded Timber fence to the
northern boundary the retention of the
existing Hedgerow to the eastern and
southern boundary and a 1.2 meter high
fence
metal railing fence to bound plot one
from The Pedestrian footpath to the West
plot one is to be cited approximately
13.5 meters from number 151 Saint Peters
Road plots two and three are to be
sighted 16 meters from numbers 139 to
149 Saint Peters Road a three-story
residential building and the proposed
residential Gardens of the development
to back onto the rear Gardens of the
dwellings along getting close
the site Falls within the bill to Parry
a boundary for chitin as inconsidered to
be a Brownfield area of land suitable
for redevelopment our set up within the
offices report it is not considered that
the development would cause harm to the
appearance or character of the area the
proposed impacts on the immunity of
existing neighboring properties is
acceptable and Warwickshire County
Council Highway Authority officers raise
no objection to the scheme officers are
satisfied that the loss of off-street
parking that would arise as a result of
the Redevelopment of the site is
acceptable and a sufficient amount of
on-site parking to serve the proposed
development is to be provided as a
result it is considered that the
development complies with policy cs26
further officers is also satisfied that
The Proposal complies with policy H1 and
E4 of the NDP it is therefore officer's
recommendation for the application to be
granted subject to the following
conditions and notes as detailed on page
60 of the agenda thank you okay thank
you very much indeed let's call our
first week of this item is cancer David
Gosling from Kyneton Parish Council
good evening Council Gosling thank you
very much for your patience you've got a
good idea of the drill you'll have three
minutes I'll give you 30 second warning
stay suited for questions afterwards
otherwise whenever you're ready it's
over to you
good evening councilors um I'm going to
ask you to consider one question this
evening and that is the fundamental one
of does the benefit of this development
outweigh the harm
as far as I can see the benefit is five
more dwellings and the removal of an
eyesore and that might be what your
conclusion is
um but before addressing the harm even
these benefits need to be challenged
the officer stated in her report that
we're not chasing housing numbers in the
district and even if we were kyneton's
already delivered significantly more
than the minimum number that was
assigned to it
even if more housing was needed for
Kyneton our recent housing needs survey
indicated that more than 50 percent of
respondents looking for an alternative
dwelling wanted a bungalow
there are none on the development of 78
homes being built now in Kyneton orbit
is selling their Bungalow stock and this
development is for two three and four
bedroom two-story dwellings and the
eyesore could be solved by maintenance
so what's the harm can I have the first
slide please there you go
when this area of counting was being
planned and built out these garages were
constructed for the benefit of anyone
owning a car and living in the houses
and flats
clearly not many were needed at that
stage
but now next photograph please many of
the houses have turned their front
Gardens into car parking areas but the
flat dwellers do not have that option
the applicant states that parking is not
allowed on the site so there will be no
displaced vehicles
um that is an interesting contrast to
the photographs that you've just seen
from the planning officer so I'm going
to say wrong there will be displaced
Vehicles they say that the garages are
not big enough for modern cars now I beg
to disagree having used one of them
myself for several years with a Volvo
estate car
they say no one wants a garage now
that's hardly surprising when you look
at them if they feel that the roof could
fall in the terms of taking out a lease
enable the owner to terminate an
agreement with one week's notice and the
rents are significantly above anything
affordable
um please just scroll through all the
other photographs
um Instead This scheme will add more
parked Vehicles onto an already crowded
Road where pedestrians can't walk on the
footpath and Emergency Services might
struggle to get through I suggest this
is the harm and please don't be swayed
by the lack of any concern from County
highways they don't live in Saint
Peter's Road
turning to planning policy H1 of the
neighborhood development plan states
that reuse of land will generally be
supported generally but not on this
occasion so the application does not
comply with this policy
part air for the development
requirements supplementary planning
document calls for separation distance
of 21 meters 30 offices own admission
this is not met the officer also notes
that the 45 degree line is breached
despite not complying with core strategy
policy cs9 the design is recommended for
approval I'm asking you to consider the
opposite thank you
Council Gosling thank you very much
indeed do we have any questions members
for our Parish Council
no council gottings thank you very much
for your time contribution this evening
we will then call our final speaker
tonight who is councilor Chris Mills
Council Mills hello
come on down you will have five minutes
for the 30 second warning towards the
end once again use as much or as little
time of that as you'd like yeah whatever
you're ready it's over to you yeah
thanks Mitchell actually there's going
to be no collaboration I can show you
with uh Council of gosling where the
photographs are almost identical about
what I've got
um yeah good evening committee um
this application should be granted will
compound the issue of the parking
problems
in the Saint Peters Road area you can
see there they're parking on the
Grassroots anywhere they can find
I'd say at the present the car owners
who live on some Peter's road we have no
off-road parking provision use this
garage area to prevent traffic
congestion and I think can you put
another photograph up with the
but you can leave it there
um
I say the residents are of some Peter's
already been forced to park on grounds
verges and footpaths which not only
wrecked the verges but also is a safety
issue for pedestrians
especially the elderly and people with
sight problems which we do have in
Kinder and we often get emails about the
traffic parks on the on the Pavements
um and they're having to walk around
uh these cars onto the road which is
very very unsafe
as you can see by the photographs clean
this redundant garage site would not
only add to the severe parking problems
which already exists therefore I've I
feel that orbit should be providing
adequate parking
facilities for their tenants
these photographs were taken during the
day where most um people are at work so
you can imagine the parking problems
late in the evening or at weekends
I believe they help orbit Housing
Association do have a duty of care in
providing adequate parking facilities
for their residents and want to
understand that affordable housing is
needed this application if granted would
only add to the parking chaos which
already exists on Saint Peter's Road
the emerging Services as Council costlin
Missouri stated there are have had
problems in the past in trying to
navigate their way through this area due
to the parking problems which only be
exacerbated should the application be
granted
in my opinion these garages which are in
a very poor condition could be removed
leaving the adequate color parking
facility which will resolve the misery
of the parking issues on some Peter's
Road
um it is unfortunate maybe from orbit
here is you know can listen to our
concerns but um
the arms chairman Ian committee I urge
you not to Grant this application thank
you
councilor Mills thank you very much
indeed members do you have any questions
for a ward member councilor Jennings
first
I'm looking at all these cars which are
showing there and you're saying all bits
should provide car parking for them are
you sure that these are all orbit
housing owners oh absolutely yes and we
I often as um Council Gosling often get
emails from uh the residents of they're
all Flats they're more majority of
Apartments you know Council meals
remember anywhere to park what it all
began to do about it that bit of green
there there would love to be seen that
turned into
a car parking facility great shame
because that will lose a bit of greenery
for um but or we won't do it
um you know it's very very costly for
them and they keep
um
saying no no no but uh yes
they are all belong to
um the residents of orbit I can assure
you that thank you
Council seraphin
um the orbit actually owned the land
where the garages are
yes they do they do they they should
have an obligation for all the people to
partner even if the garages come down
uh yeah
um
as they've said that uh there's illegal
parking on on that on the carriages
after night time they're full up all
round uh they need somewhere to go
um I think they're about 60 pounds a
month to rent which is you know for
people living in former house and they
can't afford that sort of thing so they
go onto the roads
and um
as I say is this misery for them thank
you
councilor Scala
So the plan
es stay there only four of the 44
garages are currently used so in in your
view then would it be that that is
because of the very high rents
I would say it's a lot to do with it
they are pretty darn pretty darn awful
but that's a lot to do with though put
it out the range of most of the people
who live in the apartments there yeah
Council Rock
thank you chairman
um
you will recognize that um oh I think we
would recognize the problem you're
describing for those of us with rural
villages with similar problems
but what we have before us is an
application which effectively changes
the use of that land from garages to
domestic dwellings
and you remember this planning committee
you'll no doubt recognize
what we've got in the book
um
clearly there's a strategic problem
in this locality and indeed probably
elsewhere but we've got to look what's
in front of us is there anything you you
can suggest as to how we can deal with
this problem from a planning perspective
because I can't see one yeah I agree
it's you know I can understand the need
for for housing
um and especially affordable housing
um
but it's it's just really to make
um orbit aware we're aware of their
responsibilities which they're not
taking seriously
um planning reasons is very difficult
thank you Council Dixon please
thank you chairman uh I can sympathize
with the situation here certainly my
experience however with orbit is that
when they had garages they sold them off
and then it was the new purchases that
usually then made the application for
Planning Development so obviously it's a
different situation here if it's orbit
but my question is
um
our refuse Vehicles able to get around
when those cars apart though
thank you
I'm glad you asked that um they
they do have great and honestly they do
have great difficulties
um
yeah if there is a problem
actually with the one one two three
picking up the cat is not so bad because
they're smaller vehicles but they're big
ones yes they do as I've said before the
um
the emergency vehicles have had a
problem in the past negotiating their
way through so yes there is a not all
the time but there is a problem
any more for any more I was gonna say
that we have known them direct people to
you know the Biffle
um wagons wreck people's Hedges backing
into them thank you
okay any more questions for Council
Mills please no council Mills thank you
very much thank you Mr chairman let's
face the points of clarification what
officers does anyone have anything
they'd like clarifying councilor Parry
please
thank you chair
um
a councilor Gosling made reference to
breaches to the 45 degree Rule and also
the separation distance between the
dwellings could you just um clarify that
for me thanks lanika
I'll just bring them site planet
and okay so the separation distance from
151 Saint Peters Road is 13.5 meters and
I believe councilor Gosling was
mentioning the habitable Windows
um I do have a photo of 151 which I'll
bring up shortly but that window is to
serve the hallway and then on plot one
the second floor Windows to serve an
ensuite so we could condition that that
would be obscure glazed
and then the other breach is the 45
degree angle which is number 44 Green
Farm end
um and I just think it's because due to
the location of plot five and no matter
where you put that on site there would
be a breach of that angle
um would you be able to expand further
please
um
yeah
so
um we're looking at Greenland Farm yeah
the issue you've got there is any 45
degree line that you draw will
eventually hit a building if it goes on
for long enough the point being where it
hits the building here is so far away
that the impact on daylight isn't
significant not certainly not
significant enough to refuse
okay I'll just be uh clear on you
mentioned about the episode glazing on
the ensuite plot one is that conditioned
because I can't see it in there
or is that something we might need to
add in if members think that's that's
necessary we could add that as a
condition gotcha okay thank you Council
Rock
uh thank you chairman I'd say on that
drawing that you just presented there
uh
Redline Blue Line question
um there's a blue line there that's
disappearing off the page and uh the
ward members asked a question about who
owns the other buildings and presumably
if they're in the ownership of orbit and
the applicant is orbit in
a blue line extends much more widely
than we're seeing there into these areas
where everybody's parking is that right
thank you and I have actually have a map
of the ownership of orbit so I'll bring
that
yes please yeah
so the blue line
um should include the application site
as well so everything within the blue
line is owned by the applicant orbit
so that is in control of the applicant
yeah
thank you
okay any more points for clarification
before we move to debates let's move to
debate who'd like to kick us off
someone puts a hand up or pick on
someone Council Rock first please
working oh there we go
um I feel very uncomfortable with this
application but I'm struggling how to
deal with it but this this to me this
this drawing tells all we have an
applicant here
who's got a piece of ground set aside
for parking at the moment they own a
great deal of land with a huge parking
problem
and they're coming here and asking us to
turn it into language we'll exactly
exacerbate the parking problem they've
got
um now
on a council of Parry is going to say if
we recommend refusal what what policy
are we doing under and I've just skimmed
through the book and I'm struggling to
do that but strategically
I think this is a real difficulty that
we are making a planning problem much
much worse by granting this application
and we can get into details about vision
it had 45 degree rules and all the rest
of it but strategically it seems to me
we're doing something wrong and
well I'm really unhappy about it but um
I'm struggling with the rules
councilor Perry please
thank you chair
um
rock
um unfortunately
we have to look at what's in front of us
we also have to bear in mind as in fact
the current parking situation is the
land that is the site that is in front
of us is being used by local residents
to park on whether they
um have got payment whether they rent a
garage or not
um
I'm happy with the
putting forward of school windows in
terms to avoid the ensuite and the hall
can't see a material planning reason to
refuse this this is within the built-up
area boundary it is an eyesore it is
derelict gland and if you look at the
whole
site of all that land owned by orbit
there will be parking issues throughout
the whole site not just where the
garages the garages the the this
particular site with the garages many of
which are vacant
they are not but understandably they're
not being used because of the rents
being charged
but that whole site isn't resolving the
parking problems of the expansive area
of orbit
um of of the orbit residence plus this
site does bring forward some very very
much needed affordable homes within the
village within easy reach of the Village
Center which I happen to know very well
so as much as I sympathize with the
parish council and the ward member I
have no alternative but to put forward a
proposal because I can't see a material
planning reason to refuse
just to confirm that is presumably a
proposal to Grant and you mentioned
obscure glazing Does it include that as
a condition thank you councilor Kendall
please
yes I'm gonna work for what councilor
Perry said I mean but I'm going to start
by saying in Matthew I think orbit are
failing the residence that attended
spectacularly here in terms of what
they're offering
um what in my view and I know this is an
application what they should be doing is
turning the whole thing into a proper
car park to help the existing residents
of the area
but we don't control all of it unlike
councilor Parish said there's no strong
cap well there's no planning grounds
really that I can see to go against this
so
with huge Sympathy for the problem
you're facing are reluctantly second to
The Proposal
thank you very much I think you've both
hit the nail on the head there Council
Dixon next please
thank you chairman I think it's all a
matter of how we uh read planning and uh
I'm going to ask Mr Gardner
um a question if I may in as much as we
heard from the parish council that it
was the choice between benefit and harm
and he made reference to the fact that
Guyton has already taken a large number
of housing starts
Etc and therefore uh the parish council
will take in the view that if we
actually Grant this we are harming the
area by increasing the problems with
parking and we're not actually providing
much benefits because I've already taken
a far large swathe of new housing so my
question to Mr Gardner is is there an
aspect within our planning policy where
we could actually hang our hook and do
the right thing and reject this
application
um the proper test is you make the
decision in accordance with the
development plan unless material
considerations indicate otherwise your
development plan has a housing policy in
their cs15 that indicates this site is
acceptable for development therefore
five houses are acceptable in principle
and there's a benefit to that by
bringing five new houses to the district
um
what what members have heard locally is
that there's disbenefits to the scheme
from displaced parking caused by the
loss of the garages
the County Highway Authority have looked
at this they've done a safe they've had
a safety audit done they've concluded
the highway Network would remain safe
even with the site developed so there of
the view that if there is harm it's not
significant enough to refuse so that's
why office is a recommended approval
therefore
obviously it's not for me to lead you as
to what the reasons refusal might be if
you're minded to go that way but that
that those are the two things we've had
to balance as officers
um the principles acceptable but
obviously there's local concerns around
parking we don't believe that the
parking based on our expert advice from
county is significantly harmful enough
to refuse
Castle Rock
thank you chairman of
um conscious of the fact we've got a
couple of proposals reluctantly
expressed however I found it I think but
members May disagree cs9
section two sensitive proposals
including laid out layout and
orientation will be sensitive to the
setting existing built form neighboring
uses landscape County topography at the
site and locality blah blah blah number
three distinctively will be easy to
navigate with building's design position
to enhance their hierarchy of streets
and spaces I make a character proposal
that we refuse it on the basis of cs9
two and three
okay anyone else want to talk and
debates we have got better
anyone else wants to talk and debate we
have got a proposal to grant that has
been seconded we do also have a proposal
to refuse the reasons given
I will just make the point now that uh
whilst the displacement of cars from
this site is not helpful
um I actually have experienced this very
issue on two plots within the same area
similar sort of air size area within
Smithfield Village
um so I completely understand the
frustrations and difficulties
but the landowner has the right of
access to that site and the landowner
can remove access to that site for
anyone external should they wish so that
parking could you be displaced whether
we put houses on this or not so it's
worth bearing that in mind
cancel postcard
um I'm also very
um concerned about this application I
got um I found another
policy which is um
um policy cs26
um and is
C parking standards
um and
it it does say it's about
um yeah schemes and initiatives that
address local issues such as community
Transport or safety parking congestion
and report it will be supported so
in in this application there isn't
anything that would help the local area
with the with the parking Justice place
the parking problem they haven't
um met
um the the you know the local need the
needs of the local area so I don't I
don't know whether that's something oh
yes
um it says here uh development should
not have excessive on-site parking but
provision will need to be sufficient to
avoid an acceptable impact on the
amenity of the local area
that's a sea parking standards
um policy cs26 paragraph C
I think the general guidance from what
you just said is as decision makers is
up to us to decide how much weight we
give to what you've just said and the
points you've made I made the point just
before you spoke that if orbit as
landowner is reminded to they could
cease access to this site and therefore
displaced parking anyway
um the site itself as has been presented
provides adequate parking for what is
being proposed on the site comfortably
13 car parking spaces when there is
requirement for I believe the
requirement is something like nine
so for over what their requirement is
it's worth bearing that in mind now we
have got proposals to Grant I'm going to
take that now we'll have a vote on it um
if that fails then we'll come back to
council Rock's Council proposal and see
if we've got a second before it
um so the proposal is to Grant in line
with the officer's recommendation with
the addition of the obscured glazing
condition for uh I think it was plot one
um could I please have a show of hands
for those in favor
five and those against
fall and abstentions one so committee
therefore resolves to Grant application
2200720 ful that is the Redundant
garages in Kyneton
um I presume we have no urgent business
no urgent business so it reminds me to
thank all of our officers you as members
and of course our speakers and the
members of the public that have been
involved tonight for the contributions
we'll declare the meeting closed see in
a couple of weeks thank you very much